Marvel's first family comes home but how
do we do it
Marvel has done its deal with Fox which
of course obviously means it's getting
x-men back but it also means it now gets
distribution to Fantastic Four back now
it is slightly complicated because Fox
wasn't actually producing the films they
only have the exclusive distribution but
it was another company I forget the name
of actually has the production rights
but Disney is obviously gonna get right
in with them put pressure on them and
possibly even lend resources to them or
just buy the remainder of the rights
outright whatever it takes
they will do what they need to do to get
Fantastic Four yeah I'll never hear
again the eleventh hours oh yeah they
didn't I explained back they might not
get the Fantastic Four back and I was
like well I certainly don't care anymore
well that mean there is that but I mean
they they get distribution rights the
Fantastic Four and obviously they're
planning to because Disney mentioned
Fantastic Four in its own the press
release so regardless of whether there
are there is a separate deal that has to
be done for that to happen they want it
to maybe they called out the franchise
specifically so now we're in a situation
where the Fantastic Four needs to be
integrated into the MCU and I'm done
talking about doing the x-men in the MCU
for a while because I did like three
videos in a row on it so I brought Ryan
over to talk about the Fantastic Four
what could work why not what other
things that are tied up in that license
could we now get what are some ways to
do them and I'll say I don't have a lot
to say about how I think they should
integrate the family itself because I
kind of default to the series of videos
that movie Bob did with his speculation
and I haven't thought of a better idea
I'll tell you about that in a little bit
if you're not familiar but do you have a
general notion on how to get the the
Fantastic Four into the MCU I have some
ideas but ultimately I kind of want to
just frame like like why this deal was
exciting to me and I'll get a lot of
people and and again like we discussed
this at times like the x-men there were
a lot of hits or misses with the x-men
franchise but
a fox kept x-men I would be fine with
that because it looked like they were
doing interesting things with that
franchise at least with a spinoff with
Deadpool New Mutants and things like
that there was there was gas left in the
tank for them what there was and I'm
also a person who it's interesting
seeing the x-men cross over with the
larger Marvel Universe but that's never
been something that I've needed to see
yeah cuz they're so when you bring the
x-men into the larger Marvel Universe it
opens up a lot of questions it's like
why are these people feared and
scrutinized for the way they are when
other characters might not be who have
superpowers there's just like it asks a
lot of questions that then people need
to answer well not to mention x-men has
such a huge cast of characters anyway it
doesn't need all that other stuff to be
able to be as huge and expansive right
but the Fantastic Four which is my
favorite Marvel property this is one
that I have wanted Marvel Studios to get
its hands back on not because I
necessarily want to see them interacting
with the Avengers or with spider-man
okay
crossovers are right I would love to see
them who wouldn't but the reason I
wanted Marvel Studios to get them was
because I trust Marvel Studios to do a
good Fantastic Four movie ultimately
that's what I want if you can cross them
over with spider-man or the Hulk
awesome if not just give me a good movie
because I still say the best Fantastic
Four movie to date has been the
Incredibles and then and then second to
that is the Roger Corman that one that
wasn't even theatrical released it was
like it was basically just completed to
fulfill a contract and then trying to
Hydra like try to hide away forever but
thank you bootleg copies and fanservice
the Tim story ones were mediocre they
had a couple of basically they had a
good job Johnny Storm made a good Ben
Grimm and that was kind of about it
right and I never bothered to see the
the Josh Trank Fantastic Four one I just
know
and it wasn't that I there were a couple
of things going on with that one I
looked in and said that doesn't look
like
Fantastic Four it doesn't look like but
it looks like a bad movie but also it
doesn't look like it respects the source
material getting into the question of
how do they integrate it I mean I would
love it if they could make them the
first family the premier group that
debuted before Ironman before the halt
before Spider Man because that's how
they did in the comics but that's not
possible practically I mean they could
do they could they could contrive a way
where they existed in the past like when
shield was performing but the public
doesn't know about them maybe they've
been off in a negative zone or something
like that but all that aside I just want
a good movie and they can make
differences because I like Ant Man in
the comics Hank Pym and Scott Lang the
characters wouldn't have it Ament the
movie ant-man is generously speaking it
would be generous to say that it is
representative of those characters in
the comics which is to say there's a
spark of like the characters are very
very different the the situations are
incredibly different but I still love
that movie because it felt like a was
entertaining and it was treating the
characters with respect
yeah and giving me a good product so
even though it was different and I was
like that's not my Hank Pym but this is
fine it's I mean given what Hank Pym has
been in the comics I was perfectly fine
with what we also understand the logic
for Hank and Janet Wright as they did so
they could go younger they could say the
Fantastic Four just get their powers in
the first like their first movie or
whatever that their younger generation
then then this version of Tony Stark and
this Thor and everything like they're
kind of like um Newbridge supers it
wouldn't be my ideal choice but if the
movie was good yeah I would probably be
happy with it and again sorry well to my
way of thinking there's basically three
ways to integrate okay there is
introducing them and having them get
their powers now which unfortunately
robs them of a lot of their appeal from
the comic books which is that they
are they armed or they are the most
legacy mm-hmm
characters short of Captain America
right and you lose that if you have them
get their powers now but again if you
come with a good story but the other
problem with that is especially if you
go younger and the casting is it rings
the bell of fat for steak and I know
nobody went to see it but I think
they're still gonna want to avoid ideas
that sound like they were similar to the
few ideas that thing had option number
two you bring them in from an alternate
reality where they were the first family
in what at first you know super-powered
whatever in whatever reality they were
in that's doable but I've kind of done
my own piece about why I don't want
multiverse stories in the MCU I don't I
don't particularly enjoy them inherently
but I also think that it is it is a
level of excessive complication that is
going to if not immediately fairly
quickly alienate the mainstream audience
and numb and it's gonna be something
that is gonna bring a premature
box-office death to this genre trying to
integrate that the third option which is
basically what movie Bob's suggestion
was and I will put a link down in the
description for his first video where he
outlined this part cuz he did several on
how he thought they should did the
Fantastic Four product placement
so basically his idea was they they are
from the 60s okay and you give them the
same origin in the 60s but when they and
and you know we're rewritten steals his
own experimental rocket ship to go into
space to study the cosmic rays but when
the cosmic rays they give them their
powers hit them they also knocked them
forward about sixty years into the
future okay so what that means is they
do have a legacy because like his
suggestion was initially you have them
crash and like you have like a Richards
technologies or something symbol on the
shuttle and somebody who's been around
for a while who would know that like
Tony Stark goes no no to recognize that
these people have been around but
they're only now just arriving with
their powers so you have buddy
allows them to maintain what is
admittedly a very dated family dynamic
that they were originally built with I
think in a lot of ways that's been part
of the problem with not only translating
them to film but why a lot of the more
modern comics with them have felt weird
because they're either trying to update
the family dynamic and it no longer
feels like the Fantastic Four or you
stay true to the original family dynamic
and it's so dated but if you actually
bring them all of them up forward in
time you can maintain that dynamic and
it's not like we're in it's antiquated
and justifiable way and it also creates
an interesting dynamic where folks like
Sue and Ben Grimm can benefit from
things like you know the whole yeah I
know it sounds blunt but with Ben with
the body positivity like you are you are
more than what you look like em with Sue
you know female empowerment all that
where I was all of a sudden read will
find that his father's know knows best
patriarch guy is not in fashioning good
and so there's all the the dealing with
that I don't want to get into a ton of
details of sort of the he because he
also laid out plot but as a general
starting premise I like that a lot
I would be fine with that and I kind of
thought yeah having them start in the
60s and kind of jumped forward in time
or having them flown into an ultimate
like a negative zone type of thing and
find out that they've been fighting on
nihilism his way for the last like you
know ten years or something or whatever
and they finally make their way back
whatever and basically you just create
they've been lost in space for a little
while and then like you can have
illusions to their interactions with
like the Creator the scrolls or
something in the super-skrull and that
could just be like seeded sort of
foundation that's that's stuff in their
backstory like if they you were gonna do
is I'd like I would not currently prefer
negative zone to the multiverse sort of
thing like because especially since we
haven't established the negative zone in
the MCU yet you can mess with how it
works like if they were kind of fluxing
in and out of different points in the
universe as we know it you could have
like some allusion to like they did
something that impacted accrete like a
hundred years ago or like impacted this
fifty years in the future but because
the naked
is all this year we're interweaving in
and out of our reality as we're talking
about this though I I see a problem okay
that's a marble well we don't know how
that works yet so that's kind of a
presumptive problem yeah there's a
presumptive problem but we know that her
solo movie in 2019 takes place in the
90s yes
she'll go off into space presumably to
fight the scrolls comes back for
Avengers four we don't know if she goes
off into space that's very much
speculation we know it's in the 90s we
know it involves the scrolls
I've actually been assuming that it was
largely earth set and it's gonna be more
because Nick Fury is also appearing yeah
and that it was a good it's the scrolls
because that allows you to go more
espionage because they can hide who they
are
I was not presuming a ton of space stuff
except to justify Marvel and how she
gets her powers now that's not to say
she couldn't go into space I for one
wasn't presuming that okay I kind of I
guess they could she could be in a coma
they can do I don't know they could do
something they're gonna happen they
could do the whole Avengers number 200
thing and have her go off and get and
come back and give birth to her own
rapist that went over so well in the
comics let's call that option C go go
ahead and Wikipedia that folks if you
want to read about something that was
what were they ever thinking yeah
Avengers 200 it will blow your mind
he's Aleve they made her character an
alcoholic in the nineties I know it
seems so unjustified yeah sure no that
was earned
when Tony starts up Carol you got a
problem well hard to blame her yeah so
okay so I mean I think I do if they
approached it one of these ways I think
it would be a habit because I like the
idea that they are kind of of another
generation in looking at it this way
they would almost be of Howard Starks
generation yeah maybe
research of that at the very long at
least from the yeah yeah sort of that
they would have sort of like a madman
type of
and then I'm not part of that I like
that because it not just calling them
the first family but there was always
kind of a an air of dignity about a
fantastic for that they kind of they
were the elder statesmen
yeah when something happened the Marvel
Universe that nobody couldn't explain
her that nobody was really sure about
their like is the Fantastic Four in town
no okay I got to deal with this then
yeah and yeah a bit that's kind of the
things like we need help who do we go
first the Fantastic Four the Avengers
well who's closer right basically you
just do the basic an origin story
although I don't think Marvel wanted to
do a whole lot of they want to get away
from the origin stories they kind of
said after Doctor Strange like we're
done with straightforward origin stories
so if which i think is one of the things
that makes the they they are of this
time you get their powers now angle less
likely unless it's something that they
concede in somebody else's movie or in
Avengers four we've seen their origin a
number of times just in the last 10
years in other movies or other
properties it's not super complicated
it's not it's not particularly
interesting either they I mean how they
deal with getting their powers is a
little interesting but like the actual
origin story is not particularly and
like their first big outing as heroes is
not particularly interesting either no
but I would like to at least once see
like a scene reminiscent of the cover of
their first issue with the giant yeah
when's monster coming out of the the
street just in the middle of New York I
would love to see that on film yeah I
always thought what you think if they
were doing another move like an
interesting thing because the the
question I always came up with was why
is sue on the ship with them and they've
tried to sort of say well she's a
scientist now and like they kind of
tried to present and I've never liked
that because it's like Reed is the
scientist like like I understand wanting
to give her more agency but I don't
think that was necessarily the way to go
i Ben was the pilot and you could
actually explain
Johnny having something to do with the
mechanics of building the ship or some
of these because he for being kind of a
dumb flighty jock character he's
actually really good with machines he
was always a gearhead he was always
building cars
you can put him in that what I always
took Sue's presence on the ship to be
and granted this is not from having like
a deep intimate knowledge of the
original comics but my own read on it
based off my knowledge of the characters
was she was there because of reeds
hubris like he was so certain that it
was perfectly safe why wouldn't he take
his girlfriend to show off what he can
do I would have done it doesn't even
consider to him that there would ever
possibly be a problem I would take it
even further with that I would have him
propose while they're in the ship well I
would think that was the most romantic
thing in the world and like you have a
scene where he like throws the ring at
her and you just see it tumbling through
zero-g and just before she grabs it ship
is hit by these cosmic rays and that's
it they start going through some crap
forever and then that's a visual cue
later on after the ship has crashed
somebody finds the ring or something
what you do with them then in terms of
bringing them into the larger Marvel
Universe like I said it would be cool to
have them crossing over but I think a
lot of people are expecting to sort of
see like Secret Wars from the 80s where
you've got the best Avengers the best
x-men the faint as for all these people
together and it's like and can't happen
if that was ever going to happen and had
that they didn't have to buy these guys
out half a decade ago yeah because
fortunately by the time you integrate
the Fantastic Four we're gonna need at
least two at least two solo movies
really before they're in an Avengers
movie I think and then it's like who is
your Avengers like Iron Man Captain
America Thor these guys aren't gonna be
around like they're gonna have to recast
that's not gonna feel the same so and
it's the same thing with the x-men like
looking at Avengers vs. x-men it's like
which groups starting that best they
realize and he's now set it flat out
even though he said before wouldn't it
be cool Hugh Jackman is not gonna play
ballerina again he's now said that flat
out Disney merges want him I mean that's
the other thing I wanted this was
another thing I kept getting into
arguments with with people in my comment
that they'd be like he said they'd come
back and do it like okay even if that's
true which it would later turn out no he
wouldn't but even if it was true he come
back won twice at the most they want to
sign somebody who's gonna be on the
six birdies yeah six years in ten movies
yeah oh yeah I've been playing this part
for 19 years he's done it would have
been very cool to see his Wolverine
interact with some of these characters
that is literally never going it's never
going to happen so I'm not concerned
about seeing the Fantastic Four in an
Avengers movie like with like all of
these things if it happened cool but in
terms of crossing over and meeting some
of the other Marvel characters I would
like to see them interacting with
spider-man yeah I would like to see them
interacting with the Hulk well I mean
you you have to do a thing hold fight
thank you exactly can't not do that I
would like to see them interact with
Doctor Strange yep and I would like to
see them interact with Black Panther oh
yeah with the Hulk as the notable
exception who can't have his own solo
movie for a while now so I'm not sure
what they're claiming to do with that
character and Mark Ruffalo but the other
three that I listed are all relatively
new to the MCU in terms of debuting in
their own movies just within the last
few years so I like I'm not worried
about those guys like getting out of
their contracts before they can start
moving in with the Fantastic Four so if
I'm being completely honest I do
I do enjoy the Fantastic Four in comics
I don't really care if they ever show up
in the movies yo I do care
doom I want do I know we're gonna get to
this I want doom in the MCU so bad more
than that I want him to be the next big
you know Univ Marvel Universe baddie
after thany it would be dumb for them
not to do it that way yeah yeah because
I know they're already people go no you
go Galactus after Venice like no cuz
there's no much of a repeat you don't go
that you don't try and what up yes doom
first then yes you go smaller you deal
with a guy who he's only a threat to
earth but is still a guy that throws
everybody off because he's got control
of this entire country which gives him
this diplomatic immunity thing and he
rules with Iron Fist he's got all this
technology
he ducked he does warrant the attention
of the entire at least the entire
earthbound MCU because honestly we don't
need to pull in the gardens the galaxies
for every Avengers cross Oh
following infinity war but I I want to
see I I want doom in this universe so
bad yes I agree today yeah they need
that like because I was even thinking
when I didn't think they would ever gets
when I when I didn't think they might
ever get the Fantastic Four I thought
the substitute would be king or somebody
like that who is okay no wow no one's
doing yeah nobody is doom but do and
he'll tell you that yes and then
disintegrate right and then do he taps
in it because he is a threat to the
Fantastic Four he's a threat to Iron Man
The Avengers the he's a threat to Doctor
Strange because he yeah he kind of works
as everything so I definitely think he
should be the next big bat who can play
out a long game over multiple movies
multiple years and that's another thing
it plays to his personality to be maka
Velen by Machiavelli inand to play the
long game to play a long chess game of
moving the pieces around to exactly
where he wants them to be
Thanos works for that and he works for
that structurally so he does allow you
to stretch him out over time as well
branching off from that other villains
and other characters cuz you kind of
mentioned what else besides the the core
family does this kind of byali to I uh
nihilus the sort of anihilation wave
like it the whole negative zone thing
this was the impetus for a comic book
series miniseries I guess but more like
I got maxi series that kind of event a
couple years ago that sort of kind of
created the renewed interest in the
guardians of the galaxy it sort of
anonymous and I think James Gunn has
said that he would like to do something
with that if he could possibly for
guardians of the galaxy vol 3 possibly
doing something so he he might get
access to a nihilist from that he might
I think she was already planning on
introducing Adam warlock I think he
confirmed Adam warlock
so maybe it seems like Adam warlock will
be the villain and then he has a heroic
turn we couldn't but like I mean other
other cosmic characters this might open
the door to characters like well we've
already we've seen
Kri we will have seen the scrolls but we
mentioned glasses but also Silver Surfer
they could finally do a solo so now I
was going to make sense to do that
before we see Galactus not really
something can't be completely honest
I've never cared about the Silver Surfer
like he's a baby I've just never read
the right stories but he's always felt
like a cipher to me like an overpowered
cipher he feels like a black hole of a
character he's defined by you know his
responsibilities and his powers but has
very little discernible personality it
might be it might be he is a tough
character and I think I I think it will
be it will be tough be with what they do
with Adam warlock because I think it'll
be very easy to make those two
characters very similar to the vision
and ultimately my take on Silver Surfer
has long been what I think stayin inject
wanted is basically he's the Archangel
of death who has this Redemption arc who
basically turns against God well what I
would say is you can't do a Silver
Surfer story without a Galactus um
because if I'm being again I don't think
he's interesting if he doesn't have that
hole being forced to do this horrible
thing for this massively powerful being
thing so I mean like maybe the furthest
I'd stretch it is you give him his own
movie but it has the tragic ending where
to save his own planet he now goes into
servitude of this thing like that's the
closest that I would say you should go
to giving him a solo movie devoid of
Galactus but it's that relationship that
makes him interesting and but then I
come back to what I said before we don't
we need to hold off and Galactus for a
while right and I'm still kind of the
mind of don't give him a solo movie
until he's been introduced with Galactus
in a fake passport movie yeah and that's
probably offend us for number three or
four yeah so it could be talking ten
years away well who else we got the Mole
Man we we actually did mention them
puppet master
oh my god not the red ghost and his
super Apes crazy old Russian man without
me super-powered apes oh dear Lord I
would buy that ticket I was going to say
the Inhumans well the well being humans
are stuck on TV now at this point yes
and this is this is another thing that's
funny to me cuz with some of my x-men
stuff that I put out there people like
well but see did they already introduced
the the Inhumans I'm like okay I
understand technically this is all part
of the same universe but at this point
the movies and the TV are completely
separate entities because until either
Kevin Feige or Ike Perlmutter leaves
that position the two are never going to
meaningly crossover so the fact that
they've done all this mutant esque stuff
with the Inhumans of the TV shows is
completely irrelevant to the movies but
it also means that those characters are
never going to be seen in the movies
either yeah given what we saw in the TV
show I am fine with that yeah I was one
who at the outset thought it would be
great to see these things crossover but
having fallen so far behind with the TV
watching even with the Netflix shows I
just watched the movies and have to
think yeah Agent Coulson is dead in the
movie universe no he really is yeah
that's yeah that was the intention and
that's you're sticking with that but the
thing is it's funny a lot of much like
themselves like we talked about
initially with how the Fantastic Four is
kind of a dated family unit a lot of
their villains are really dated to like
like Mole Man he's kind of fun but he's
really sixties cheesy sure and well a
lot of them are doom is too but doom is
in a way that works right going back to
my initial thing is I want I want a
movie that is just good that is it can
be different it doesn't have to be a
carbon copy of the comics because the
movies haven't been well know yet man
was not basically comics but it all
needs to be done there was never a comic
book version of the guardians of the
galaxy that looked and sounded like that
movie until after that movie came out
yeah it's been so it's been to the
movies benefit that they have never
directly adapted in a specific store
right so if you give me a dynamic that
feels like a general
no family that they're not all content
they're not all 21 years old or whatever
they were in fan-forced at the very
least they need to be very well that you
have a sense of age and like a gap and
everything with Johnny being the kind of
younger kid brother and Su having to
manage him and read as this kind of like
elder statesman and if you if you make
them fun and you make them likeable but
above all what I really want for these
movies you've got to show me something
different and this is ambitious and the
the bankability of the franchise would
not want this at now but I want Disney
to treat the Fantastic Four movie like
James Cameron treats avatar which is we
need to invent new technology that
doesn't exist right now in order to show
you what you need to see to experience
this like like 250 million dollar
production budget for this like going
crazy
so they exactly you can really go nuts
with things like the negative zone and
and the nation the notion of them as
explore quantum feel the the astral
realms that we saw in amen and Doctor
Strange
those are a good start but let's dig in
yeah yeah and like a director of
photography who really kind of gets like
bold and does some crazy experimental
stuff that was what made the comics
special was for a hundred issues Jack
Kirby just did stuff that nobody else
was doing that nobody else could even
think of and part of the problem is
people have been trying to eat that
feeling for so long and very few
succeeded that's true I think
unfortunately that
marbles in a slightly on enviable
position when it comes to trying to deal
with the Fantastic Four because
obviously you know trying to do
something that is true to the original
version of the comics it wasn't good but
the Tim story movies were that again
they weren't good but they were those
characters more or less at least on
paper as they were from the comics and
then fan-forced ik was let's reinvent
the
characters as something else so now
there's already a taint on honoring the
original and a taint on reinventing so
that that puts them in an awkward
position where they need to reinvent but
also not reinventing the way it was
already reinvented and didn't work I'm
kind of more interested in what they're
gonna do with Fantastic Four that accent
which is not to say I don't care about
x-men but for me there's there's a
little bit more of a mourning involved
with Disney acquiring x-men because I am
feeling a little bit of a loss of what
else might Fox have done that Disney
won't do whereas I don't have it those
that kind of hang ups with Fantastic
Four it's like do whatever you want
I don't care at this point and yeah and
I'm kind of my interest in my enthusiasm
for the x-men is not what it was when I
was in half my age but certainly I I
would be curious to see what they would
do because I haven't been wowed by the
last couple of solo x-men movies
I appreciate Deadpool for being
something very different even though it
wasn't necessarily to my taste I like
the idea that Bob Iger has pretty much
said we are open to keeping that an
r-rated franchise that can sort of exist
within the Marvel Cinematic Universe as
long as we kind of make it clear to our
audiences like let them know that that
and I actually think Deadpool can
transition almost seamlessly because of
the his fourth because he's a
fourth-wall break because like he gets
away yeah you can say say hey are you a
different actor who played Colossus or
like something you can like he can wait
I could totally see him in Deadpool 3
turning here wait we're all by Disney
now am I still allowed to say this yeah
well you don't look good hang a
lampshade on it it would be fine it
would work for that character that would
be perfect so but not concerned about
Deadpool's future in Disney I'm not
either but at the same time like I still
go back to and I mean I wasn't expecting
Bob Iger to kill Deadpool's a franchise
because aside from the fact that it's
very successful that would have cost him
a hell of a lot of audience should
oh sure and I think he knew that but
what I will say is Disney won't kill it
now but Disney also wouldn't have made
that movie in the first place No so I am
still concerned about yeah no they don't
think where they're gonna go they never
would have taken the risks for the movie
like Logan no Deadpool or things like
that now that they have already been
made maybe they will still do things in
those veins but I also can't let go the
fact they wouldn't have made those
movies in the first place so but that's
kind of a separate thing we've now
wandered we know but yes Fantastic Four
doom whoo so that's I think we'll wrap
it up on this one
Bryan what do you feel like plug in
these days I've got a number of shows in
the fire and water podcast
get them while they're hot because a lot
of them will go on hiatus and 2018
yeah podcast network find me I mean I I
plug that anyway because I have a
podcast on there too so what are your
thoughts on the Fantastic Four how do
you integrate it into the MCU what
characters should or shouldn't they use
from the supporting cast or villains
whatever your thoughts are drop
something down in the comments let's
talk about it don't forget to like
subscribe check me out on Twitter at
council of geeks give a listen to the
council of geeks podcast that's
available on Apple podcast and stitcher
radio I'm also one half of the punch
like a girl podcast which along with
Ryan stuff is on the farm water podcast
network farm water park show is all
never ending and until next time this
council is adjourned
[Applause]
[Applause]